climbers attempting to summon mount
everest and stand on the top of the
world have their work cut out for them
dangers are everywhere on the long climb
there's a risk of extreme altitude
sickness unpredictable winds and
freezing weather there's also the threat
of avalanches great unstoppable tidal
waves of snow that can bury a person
alive in seconds or strand them leaving
them to freeze to death cold and alone
it's a sad reality that not everyone
that visits everest comes back down
again and rarely does a climbing season
go by that the mountain doesn't claim
yet another victim situated on the
border between china and nepal in a
sub-range of the himalayas of tibet
everest is one of the seven wonders of
the natural world with an elevation of
29 031 feet or 8
848 meters mount everest has attracted
many experienced mountain climbers over
the decades but even for the most
experienced mountaineers the ascension
up its snowy slopes is far from easy
deaths occurring on mount everest are
nothing new and hundreds of people are
believed to have died attempting to
ascend the treacherous peak sadly due to
the risks involved with carrying heavy
loads down off the mountain many of
those who die on everest are doomed to
stay there forever their frozen bodies
serving up as their own grave markers
it's difficult enough to move your own
body up and down everest and in many
situations bringing a body back down is
simply impossible the bodies of these
lost souls are scattered all across and
sometimes underneath the surface of
mount everest but some of those bodies
are different from the others and have a
special name within the files of the scp
foundation they call them scp-5140
scp-5140 is the designation given to a
number of frozen bodies which are found
all across everest it is unclear exactly
how many instances of scp-5140 there are
though some estimates have placed the
number of somewhere between 1 and 200.
at present it is unknown if all the
instances of scp-5140 are dead bodies
belonging to climbers who met tragedy on
the tallest mountain in the world or if
some of them are something else entirely
but while their origin is unclear if you
come into contact with a 5140 instance
there won't be any doubt that it's
different from the normal body of a dead
climber that's because
scp-5140 corpses are a lot like vampires
in some ways that isn't to say that they
actually are vampires they certainly are
not undead and cannot function after
death but much like a vampire
traditionally drains blood to survive
these bodies drain heat
scp-5140 corpses are ecto-entropic
meaning they do not adhere to the normal
laws of thermodynamics whenever these
cadavers are exposed to sources of heat
including human body heat the corpse
will instantly drain the source of any
and all thermal energy however the
temperature of these
scp-5140 bodies remains the same
regardless of how much heat they are
able to drain staying at a constant 50
degrees fahrenheit or 10 degrees celsius
should any living person come into
direct contact with one of the scp-5140
corpses the body will absorb their
natural body heat bringing their victims
own temperature down to 10 degrees
celsius and causing them to die and once
they have died their body then becomes a
new instance of scp-5100
as a quick side note this might feel
vaguely reminiscent of another anomaly
which features seemingly inert dead
bodies that are hazardous to anyone
around them
scp-2316 this anomaly is a powerful
mimetic hazard consisting of a large
number of drowned human corpses these
corpses are extremely hazardous to
approach at even a considerable distance
as the memetic hazard inherent to the
anomaly causes those affected to
recognize the bodies in the water as
people they know particularly from their
childhood like a siren's call the
victims are lowered into the water
believing that the familiar bodies are
calling to them if the victims aren't
stopped quarantined and given them
neastic treatment they are essentially
considered lost they will walk into the
water and be absorbed into the
collective becoming just another body
floating in the water while the
foundation doesn't currently believe
that there is any official connection
between the two anomalies the
similarities are undeniable and worth
taking into consideration moving on at
present it is unclear whether scp-5140
corpses are caused by some sort of
infection or parasite that spreads among
the bodies uncovered at mount everest if
this is the case the foundation has yet
to uncover the patient zero the root
cause of these infected bodies there is
also little to determine why a deceased
body requires the absorption of heat as
well as how it achieves this and also
keeps its own temperature low but not
frozen given that interacting with an
instance of scp-5140 can be fatal it
does seem that these anomalous
properties can be passed through contact
and exposure like a disease or parasite
but there have been no observed
anomalous effects among any living
person visiting mount everest there is a
possibility that the scp-5140 corpses
have developed some form of posthumous
mutation that has come as a result of
being killed during an everest avalanche
and buried in the snow their bodies
starved of heat after death after all
everest is known for its cold
temperatures occasionally reaching as
low as 1 degree fahrenheit or minus 17
degrees celsius not to mention the
difference in air pressure at such high
altitudes as well as frequent high-speed
freezing cold winds at the summit of
mount everest wind speeds can reach up
to 280 kilometers per hour that is
equivalent to
175 miles per hour and high speed winds
have even been known to catch mountain
climbers off guard and send them
plummeting to their deaths perhaps the
combination of these conditions the
freezing temperature the air pressure
and the winds have triggered some sort
of change in a number of the bodies
unfortunate enough to never leave the
snow-covered slopes of mount everest
either that were these abandoned corpses
left in such extreme cold could be the
perfect home maybe some form of unknown
and so far undetected parasite is
capable of inhabiting these frozen
bodies and can spread to other living
hosts by draining them of their body
heat stranger things have certainly
happened at the scp foundation and that
could possibly explain why anyone
interacting with an scp-5140 corpse
meets the same grizzly fate regardless
of what causes these abnormalities or
why the scp-5140 bodies have only been
uncovered at mount everest close contact
with the corpses often result in
casualties and fatalities naturally this
is a cost the scp foundation likes to
avoid as often as it can the nasty habit
scp-5140 corpses have of draining a
person's body heat makes it impractical
to bring them back to a foundation
research facility for testing as does
the fact that they're on the tallest
mountain in the world instead mtf delta
14 have been tasked with keeping these
heat thirsty cadavers contained to mount
everest mobile task force delta 14 also
known under the code name winter
wonderland is formed of a group of
particularly adept mountaineers and
experts in understanding and adapting to
particularly brutal terrain without
drawing attention to themselves these
covert operatives are tasked with
periodically climbing mount everest and
keeping
scp-5140 contained it is this team's job
to locate any new instance of scp-5140
bodies and bury them in the snow in
doing so the goal is to prevent any
unwitting mountain climbers from
stumbling upon one of these bodies and
potentially becoming a new instance
themselves meanwhile the foundation is
pushing for both nepal and tibet to
tighten restrictions on climbing permits
but of course the money that mount
everest tourism brings to these two
countries has likely impeded this
according to the foundation's file on
scp-515
an incident occurred during one of
mobile task force delta 14's annual
everest expeditions members of mtf delta
14 had been traversing towards the
everest summit encountering more and
more of the scp-5140 bodies as they made
their way up the mountain just as they
were instructed to do so the team buried
each of the frozen corpses they came
across under a blanket of snow the delta
14s noticed though that there had been a
much higher number of the frosty
cadavers on this mission speculating
that perhaps mount everest's high winds
had blown the snow off of ones they had
already buried on previous missions one
of the delta 14s a man named charlie
smith was in correspondence with his
colleagues at their base camp charlie
reported that one of his fellow winter
wonderlanders patrick had touched one of
the scp-5140 corpses when the team
reached the summit and that he was now
buried according to protocols after
becoming an
scp-5140 instance himself as they began
their descent from atop everest charlie
sent an urgent communication to base
camp reporting that he uncovered three
more
scp-5140 bodies at an abandoned campsite
except these three instances were
different from any he had encountered
before these corpses were somehow still
moving attempting to hurry down the
mountain charlie reported that a mass of
scp-5140 corpses were blocking his path
and draining another one of his squad
mates arnold of his body he to make him
one of them arnold had been carrying the
team's provisions including their oxygen
reserves to combat the lack of
breathable air at mount everest's high
altitude charlie tried in vain to use
his flare gun to clear the path hoping
to distract the now walking cadavers
with a heat source but it had no effect
his final message to base camp warned
the rest of delta 14 to not come to the
summit of everest with charlie
frantically urging them to not let
climbers anywhere near it his final
message simply stated that the mountain
is danger a rescue division of mobile
task force delta 14 arrived just under
two hours later tracking charlie's last
known location via a gps beacon
strangely despite the frantic messages
from charlie there were no signs of any
scp-5140 instances none of the piles of
corpses he had warned them about could
be seen above the snow and certainly
none of them were moving it wasn't long
before the rescue team found charlie
though he was dead but not drained of
heat or turned into another instance of
scp-5140
no sadly after bringing their fallen
comrade back to base an autopsy revealed
that charlie had died likely the same
way so many other climbers on everest
had he had suffered from a lack of
oxygen further examination of his gear
revealed that charlie's oxygen intake
valve had been damaged earlier while the
squad had been climbing to the summit of
mount everest his teammates arnold
hillary and patrick edmund were also
discovered on the mountain but only
patrick had been turned into an scp-5140
instance arnold had simply died from
exposure just like charlie the rescue
team concluded that due to lack of
adequate oxygen charlie smith had
hallucinated the site of scp-5140
corpses moving and blocking his path
spending his final moments in terror as
the mountain's conditions slowly killed
him the foundation is still unsure
exactly what caused his bodies to become
instances of
scp-5140 or even how many of them are on
everest but a major and troubling
development has recently been made after
an increase in global temperature led to
a large avalanche that resulted in a
large portion of the mountain that had
previously been covered in thick snow
being exposed the foundation sent planes
that were equipped with thermal imaging
equipment to scan the mountain what they
found was as confusing as it was
terrifying the scp-5140 corpses aren't
just spread across the surface amount to
everest they are much of everest the
mountain itself is just a huge pile of
corpses just waiting to drain the life
from anyone who attempts to scale it and
turn them into a permanent part of the
peak so if you were planning a trip to
the himalayas hoping to scratch climb
mount everest off your bucket list maybe
give it a pass otherwise you might find
that the climb is even colder than you
were expecting now check out
scp-1861 the crew of the hms
wintersheimer and
scp-3082 neverlands lost boys and girls
for more mind-boggling mysteries from
the scp foundation